all right welcome everybody we are back
again as promised with the second stream
of the day this is going to be a
uh probably the last stream before our
vacation which starts after the friday
show is done tomorrow
um we streamed a press briefing earlier
we were waiting for donald trump in
michigan where he is
probably not too far from landing um i
guess he left over a half hour
40 minutes ago more than that actually
from the white house and it's quite a uh
it's quite a short flight
indeed um so we are waiting for
touchdown we are keeping an eye on a fox
news feed we are keeping an eye on a pbs
news feed
i'm going to show you guys something
funny just because i
this was pointed out to me this is right
side broadcasting and they have
errors in both english and spanish
on this thing that's scrolling on their
screen so first of all
it says
now what they want to say is in person
but what that means is
personally like let's vote personally
which is a little weird but it's
pandering to latino voters okay
but then they also have an element up on
screen
that i've never seen before which is as
you can see here november 3rd
3 e r d november
3rd if you will
and that i've never seen um
in any case this is right side
broadcasting
we are not um going to be looking
you know super super closely at that uh
donald trump's lectern is covered in a
blanket
i've not seen that before but that i
guess is interesting as well there's a
guy crawling around on the stage which
is interesting so okay
we are here and we're going to do it and
let's see
let's see we i saw the double um the
double apostrophe on let's i did see i
just you know it's like
yeah pick your battles right pick your
battles so
we have a lot of really interesting
things going on
surrounding the show some of which i
will be telling you about momentarily
some of which i'm going to hold on to a
little bit later i do have one fresh
meme
i did some meme review earlier in the
stream earlier today
in my other stream and i was not
anticipating any fresh memes for you
but i do have one fresh one hot off the
press
that i will be showing people a little
bit later a little bit later oh i guess
is it raining is that why they've got a
blanket on the lectern maybe that's what
it is i don't know
it's always very difficult to know what
is going on at any of these
uh trump it's covered in case it rains
okay
very good so we're gonna get to meme
review a little bit later
um updates on coronavirus uh we still do
have a pandemic in this country we've
not done this for a while but we are now
at 196
000 deaths donald trump will tell you
we're doing better than any country now
we actually have
the uh 11th worst per capita death rate
in the world
out of more than 200 countries and
territories
um 34 000 new cases today
866 deaths yesterday
similar number of new cases 35 000 but
1200 deaths yesterday so we still have
we still have a situation uh and i know
most of you know that but it seems that
there are people out there
uh pretending that this is not going on
so that it whoa
diamond and silk you know i'm going to
close this out because the toxicity
level is too high
we're going to keep it here i think this
is probably a good stream for now and
then eventually we should be able to get
um we'll let's let's pop open a
bloomberg
feed and then eventually i it is now
is the white house feed not able to do
it because it's a campaign
event let's see trump 2020 maybe there's
a
trump 2020 channel um
fox news comes up when you search for
that that's interesting no
all right so anyway we we have a few
different streams and i think we're
probably going to be okay so we'll get
back
to that and and we're we're going to be
fine expecting donald trump landing i
would guess somewhere in the next seven
or ten minutes here
okay um thanks to a whole bunch of
people i want to say thanks to moondog
for subscribing with twitch prime it is
september
moondog subscribes with the message
convalescent
plasma skillet queso
subscribes with prime and drifter 77 has
subscribed as well
super chats are happening bay photo says
via super chat thanks for everything you
do david plazman
1 million soon so listen i was going to
wait a little bit
because i want to get um
as many people in here before i
do this but we are
only about 3 500 subscribers on youtube
away
30 hold on 3 600 uh from 1 million
and we could conceivably get to 1
million on stream today
if we don't it's probably going to
happen during the vacation which will be
so
anticlimactic so i would love to do it
right now during the stream now there's
four it's it's funny because
we need 4 000 and there's 4 000 people
watching on youtube right now
but a lot of the people watching on
youtube are already subscribed
and you just like you can't vote twice
you can't subscribe twice to the same
channel
so i'm gonna come back to this a little
bit later
but it is it is certainly doable we were
at 993 before
the first stream today now we're at 9.96
and a half
this only updates every thousand but on
my phone i can tell you we're at 996
400. um so
needless to say imagine if we actually
got to the million
during this okay um in terms of memes
a few things to show you this is a deep
fake
of me as trump some people like this
some people were disturbed by it i will
show it to you just so you can get a
sense of it
this is donald packman
there you go so that one's that um one
other meme i did this earlier but i told
you i i was gonna
be redoing a few of the same memes i
posted this to my instagram not long ago
this is me
with some of my prepping materials
including
a head-mounted lamp as a headlamp i
guess you would call it
and some people call it a headlamp
that's a term i've never heard before
but that i think i just came up with
that
who do i sound like and then here is a
medical kit and somebody turned this
into my medical plasma kit as you can
see here
ready to help people outside of a white
house that is exploding i guess
never leave home without your medical
plasma bag
very very important and then one fresh
meme from earlier i'm sure many of you
have heard
of um the legal eagle
who does really really great videos this
is the legal eagle
investigation as to whether my
membership discounts
are too outrageous discount
so low it becomes illegal
legal eagles real law review 66
off two dollars per month that may not
be legal in many
many parts of the world and we're going
to get back to that
a little bit later as well so a lot of
very exciting things
as you can see here they are very
carefully wiping down
the the handrails because of the
possibility this is actually
interesting they have to be sure trump
doesn't fall on his face trump as you
know
struggles often to walk up and down
stairs and ramps
and so they are really trying to keep
everything as dry as possible
because imagine if donald trump were to
suffer a fall
while getting up on the podium and up to
his lectern
so they're looking at that extremely
carefully
a few other super chats that are coming
in
um kjv says hey david your hair looks
great today what salon do you go to and
do you go there without a mask
if so be sure to scapegoat the owners no
i got my haircut last week i was fully
masked the entire time i was
i did not the only thing i did was when
it was time to do sideburns and around
the edges
i pulled off one side and you know
she took care of that area put it back
on then pulled off the other side the
other area
and it felt it felt quite safe it felt
quite safe
scrumptious says i am from canada and i
am worried about russian misinformation
influencing our citizens i see it all
over youtube and i am worried what are
your thoughts
of course and we've been covering that
extensively for a long time i wish the
president was worried about it
i wish you know mitch mcconnell was
worried about it
but alas they are not so what we have to
do is overwhelm the polls i wish it were
different
but that is uh that is the reality let's
make sure that we're in hd
here on all of these streams uh we just
want to do
full hd pbs not quite live yet
okay fair enough we're still standing by
haven't missed anything yet
um thanks to exclamation kate and nova
bombshell
for subscribing with twitch prime also
thanks to big bad greg
who subscribe and says thanks for what
you're doing dave concerned canadian
yeah there's worry all over the world
truly
stephen robbins is here saying d-man
it's ray-gun do you have a spa
do you have a favorite spanish swear i
don't
i don't um speaking of which though
for people standing by for the spanish
language content
i do have a 40-minute interview i was
interviewed in spanish
last week uh by on a puerto rican
podcast i'm in the process of
translating it
uh so that it will be captioned not
dubbed
we're we're you know we're we're not
children we're going to caption it not
dub it
and um that'll publish next week during
our vacation so i think that that you
guys will find that interesting
and if you don't you don't have to watch
it that's the beautiful thing
excuse me steve jennings says i'll sub
but i feel like i'm cheating on sam
cedar this is the thing about the race
to a million
you can subscribe to multiple youtube
channels
it does sam is not hurt by you
subscribing to me
because you can also subscribe to sam i
would actually
uh oh are we seeing the plane oh god uh
oh no it's just a chopper
i would actually propose something which
is if
if if we got to 1 million subscribers on
stream
i will actually play sam cedar's
congratulation video to me
which it's it's edgy let me just put it
that way i will play
that video on stream if we get to the
million subscribers during this stream
okay crimson el rick has subscribed for
12 months with twitch prime and says hi
david my 11 year old son alex is working
hard to become a pro tennis player
could you say some words of
encouragement for him oh boy i don't
know that this is my uh
my bailiwick bailiwick i don't know much
about tennis or
children but what i would say is with a
dad like crimson elric
i can't imagine you will be led astray
alex
and what i've learned i've learned a few
things that are general advice
and i don't want to uh lead you astray
number one
showing up is more than most people are
willing to do so just keeping at it
tends to put you in the top 50 or 60 of
people right off the bat
uh and then and then deliberate
careful practice deliberate careful
practice
uh can get you into the top five percent
and then you only have to get way better
to become a pro tennis player so
i hope that that's encouraging in some
sense titan mars pred if not
don't show it to him titan mars
productions has subscribed for
six months with twitch prime as we do
have
a hype train going
grillium 7.6 says david
please just say john paydick is cool
all right john patek is cool
thanks and welcome to kratos as well as
progressive
trance that could be a political
statement or a musical statement
progressive trance could be a could
really have a double meaning
bae photo says wow six pacman let
himself go
now donald pacman right
mab says thanks for guiding us through
donald old and wrong trump's hugely
tragic failings when are you on the joe
rogan experience next
nothing scheduled as of yet nothing
scheduled as of yet
star barf beautiful has subscribed with
twitch prime
i also want to say thank you to jamie
nunes
and lori gongoware jamie and laurie our
new members number one and two today at
joinpackman.com
and i do very much appreciate that mike
i gotta be careful with this one mike
mike um brisk brave
brigadiers brandish broad bright blades
blunderbusses and bludgeons balancing
them
badly that is a mouthful mike wow
doug hawkins has subscribed eduardo
arrow semena
says here for the one million subscriber
milestone
felicidades love it
five to one says flush the turd
on november 3 i like that
i like that oh by the way um
it appears as i know some of you here
are waiting to see if we get to a
million subscribers during this live
stream
we have entered some kind of highly
monitored stage
on youtube where i think it's because
sometimes like 300 people will sign will
subscribe at once because we're getting
very close to a million
the numbers don't update right away it
seems that there's some kind of like
verification
that's going on my guess is youtube
has some way of verifying that we're not
getting to one million
fraudulently or fraudulently as some say
um so the numbers are it's sort of
updating in bunches we're now
at 996 650
okay so we're at 33.50 to go
incredible i mean really really
incredible stuff that that's uh
that we are this close unbelievable
bryce
elder says first game of the nfl season
tonight will trump get sweaty and then
angry tweet if there is kneeling
yes yes oliver wilde says how's the drum
addendum to plasma going hope you have a
relaxing week off yeah i mentioned on my
earlier stream that i have not yet
figured out exactly the right setup for
adding drums to the plasma track
joseph woodward developed this song this
is maybe the song
of the summer um and i'm gonna play it
for you momentarily but i he also sent
me a drum
free track which i then will add drums
to
but i'm still getting my recording setup
figured out but this is the track
hey i'm pleased to make a truly historic
announcement in our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
really catching operation
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
people looking for that sweet sweet
plasma
[Music]
convalescent
so anyway i'm going to eventually be uh
how
how crazy is it that this is my job uh i
will be adding drums to that
um once i get my my recording setup
figured out
it does seem like there is sort of a the
crowd is a buzz and as you can see not
very few masks inside and we are calling
these corona rallies
i'm guessing donald trump's plane is
relatively nearby
oh you hold on excuse me i need to ban
someone i apologize for that
um there are just some pricks in the
chat
and we don't uh we don't tolerate it
here but they're gone
they're gone thanks to diane goodman
who's new member number three today at
joinedpakman.com
and angela burns is new member number
four at joinedpakman.com anticipating
uh donald trump landing i guess soon or
maybe any second which is why
maybe these camera people are facing the
other way let's see if we've got any
other angles here
no um and my guess is trump's bringing
the small plane people have asked why
the small plane has been out lately
i think it's two things i think number
one
they're landing at some smaller airports
which may just not be equipped to handle
a 747 that's one possibility
um the other may be that the 757 is
simpler logistically
in terms of the rolling stairs in terms
of boarding i'm not sure i'm just
speculating
and or maybe it's a financial thing i
mean it's certainly
cheaper um now the other thing is
because these are campaign events in
theory it's conceivable that the
that the campaign is supposed to
reimburse the government
for the flights if so certainly you
would imagine that it's cheaper to fly
the 757 than the 747 but
is trump actually is the trump campaign
actually reimbursing the the government
for the flights
who the hell knows probably not right i
mean it's just they don't uh
it doesn't they don't really do anything
they're supposed to do so who knows
okay other super chats coming in let me
see here
um leanne o'neill says of
all the woodward revelations i think
today's khashoggi drop disturbs me the
most what are your thoughts i actually
didn't see that yet leanne
i have been in streaming hell for the
last many hours so i didn't see that
sarah strohmeier says love your style
david my four cats are big fans of yours
congrats on a million and enjoy your
break thank you
grumpy modeler says it took me 13 years
to get to a thousand subs on youtube
what's your secret
i don't know that there is any secret
it's just making content
we've been do we've been on youtube for
11 years
uh in some way shape or form and we are
potentially just
hours hours from hitting one million i
think that's it
oliver wilde says thank you for playing
that it always makes me laugh
trevor smith says mr law and order said
whoa says we have a great relationship
with the taliban
americans with a brain you said what
yeah when trump during his earlier press
briefing says he he's getting along
great with the taliban
it was odd it was very odd shannon
bennett says tony williams or neil
pierce
don't hedge man have an opinion um i'm a
big rush fan so just for for lack of
being milk toast i will say neil piert
captain flank says does the republican
party implode in 24
if donald goes for a third term guys
he's not going for it give me a break
i think half of them can't stand by and
will want someone else on the ticket
oh and the 747 coming in out of nowhere
so i was wrong
so i guess in theory uh it was runway
size
that was uh responsible for the 757
choice but
uh bringing bringing the big boy the
double stairs as you can see and
a lot of powerful elements of aviation
as you can see here
big thanks to karen frank who's new
member number five today
and liberty hussein who is new member
number six
at joinedpakman.com um
thanks to fluffer stumps for gifting a
subscription on twitch
thanks to milkman u
um thanks to fluffer stumps for the
subscription
dj piggyback has subscribed deep fried
yaddy has gifted five subscriptions
dr aud has subscribed
a lot happening a lot happening on
twitch here
um welcome if you are watching on
youtube twitch or facebook we
are potentially i guess 10 minutes from
the start
of this trump rally uh it does take a
little while to get
people off the plane and to get
everything situated
so to speak um ali lee says any thoughts
on trump's response to hurricane laura
underwhelming i guess i would say
we are now at the point at which someone
asks whether i look at twitch
chat and of course i do thank you for
asking it we we were at that point in
the stream
daraten says all the woodward's drop in
truth on trump
subba says cool shirt where'd you get it
i have no idea
probably j crew i don't know
uh richard says hey david richard from
seattle i am the crimson el rick from
twitch thanks so much for your
nice words of encouragement for my son
my pleasure
thanks to jem annabelle says does it
concern you that 16 states don't have
faithful electoral voter laws
so electoral voters can choose
differently from the people
it concerns me in some vague sense i
don't believe it will be a factor
i don't think it's going to play any any
kind of role
other super chats guy fox says keep up
the good work let's get the cheeto
in charge out of here we're working on
it
we're working on it thanks to linka 1972
for subscribing with twitch prime
thanks to l.o.i per lipper
for subscribing with prime as well
really appreciate it
i um donald trump in sort of some vague
sense was scheduled to speak for an hour
and 20 minutes tonight that's an
outrageous amount of time
especially when the pace of speech is so
slow
and the content is so laughable we will
see
uh to what degree donald trump speaks
uh 80 minutes tonight which is just a
lot
or hopefully he will make it a quick one
i think that actually trump would
benefit from making these far far
shorter
um let's see here other
um super chats and messages that are
coming in
chase axelsson says happy early 1
million subscribers
mike thole says where's that loose
cannon machuchin at yeah some some of
you guys might
there was a call last week where a
viewer called in and said they didn't
like what stephen machuchin was doing of
course as you know it's mnuchin it was a
really great call chakaseki says today's
press conference was a tragic implosion
blaming woodward for not going public
with coronavirus lies
is insane orange juicillini
marches on yes and we are waiting i
guess for the plane to turn around at
the edge of the runway
must be close to entering our shot here
as the phones are being held up
and then i i would still imagine we are
10 to 15 minutes
from the uh from the from the start of
donald trump's
screed if i had to guess
if i had to guess thanks to deep state
agent for subscribing on twitch with the
message
deepak as a guest commentator on chris
hayes show when
probably never msnbc has never liked me
fox news has had me on
um cnn has had me on
i've been on siriusxm radio msnbc has
never
once had me on and i don't imagine i'm
going to get that call anytime soon
which is fine to be perfectly to be
perfectly frank
it's much much easier to just hang out
at home and stream to be totally honest
danny says you know you are living in a
weird world when a u.s
president doesn't even mention the west
coast wildfires
in his pressers that's what he should be
called out on yeah
is he even aware of it who knows who
knows
what kind of audio do we have
okay not hugely surprising i guess
we're gonna we're gonna keep that muted
for the time being let me say thank you
to linda sharp who is new member number
seven today
i also want to say thank you to darren
cuiard
who is new member number eight you know
in the earlier
stream today we had 106
new members it was a record we have
never had
106 new members during a stream before
that was earlier
very different situation right now
nothing to
say says is it just me or is trump doing
a lot of things that charles lindbergh
did in the plot against america tv show
now he is even doing fly-in speeches
there are certainly some overlaps yeah
no there's no question about that
there's no question about that um
have i ever thought about writing a book
yes i have i just have not come up with
a good
a good uh idea a good concept unless i
feel really good about the concept i
don't wanna put
you know uh six to twelve months or as
some
grifters have done it in a month a book
i don't want to put a month into a book
that's not going to be that good i
definitely don't want to put
6 to 12 months into a book that's not
going to be that good
this is a beautiful opportunity to get
your super chats on screen
chase asks what's the process for going
on tv it seems stressful
well in non-coveted times they
there's this insane thing that happens
where when you get booked on cnn fox or
msnbc well msnbc i can't
say but on cnn or fox um
they act like these four minutes you're
gonna be on air are like the most
important thing in the world and lives
are depending on it so
they will have for someone will first
invite you then they will have someone
prep you for the for what's going to be
discussed
they're gonna do you want to ride when i
lived in new york city i would take the
ride
um then you know makeup and all this
oh the host the host is thinking that
they may actually do
five and a half minutes instead of four
minutes okay
i don't does that affect me in some way
it's really weird actually
uh the amount of you would think that
we're you know splitting the atom here
with a four minute segment
um but then you just sit in a room they
always want you there super early
probably because some people unlike me
i'm extraordinarily reliable some people
probably are not very reliable
so they want you just sitting in the
chair with your earpiece in like a half
hour early
super annoying which is why i've stopped
accepting the ride
if i accept the ride they're like we'll
pick you up 90 minutes before the
segment
if i drive myself or just get an uber uh
i get there you know seven minutes
before or whatever
um and uh then it just it happens
and then it's very abrupt where they
just cut it and then they you know
somebody will say in your ear
thank you this is if you're not in the
actual studio if you go to a satellite
studio thanks very much
and then that's it then you just you
just leave you walk out with your tail
between your legs is essentially the way
it goes
um okay james justice says over
under on three and a half minutes for
how long it takes trump to mention
whitmer aka that woman
i think he's not going to mention her
during the first three and a half
minutes that's my guess
that's my guess robert baldwin says what
do you think about right side
broadcasting promoting coins with q and
other trump propaganda on them
uh they're they're out of completely out
of their minds i have no other thoughts
beyond that
b.j blitz says how do you watch these
things and survive david
i have four tvs five of them are on
basketball right now
so i'm only tangentially paying
attention to this
that's a joke by the way um
okay alejandro sanchez says you should
have kyle on during the election night
stream that would be something to look
at yeah
daniel daly says david have you heard of
the band portugal the man
yes if so what do you think of them and
all the great socio-political activism
they do i unfortunately don't know
anything about the socio-political
activism
but i like the music all right listen
guys
i am going to offer you something
illegal and immoral right now
and i'm going to off ask i'm going to uh
offer it
humbly okay this program the channel
staff salaries the lights and we have a
lot of lights in here
you till everything our number one
funding source is people who go to join
pacman.com and grab a membership
okay now right now you can get a
discount the discount code is 2020 now
and it saves you 66
i want to warn you though legal eagle
is worried that these discounts may be
so big that they are against the law
all right illegal discounts discount
so low it becomes illegal
legal eagles real law review okay
if you're not worried about taking
advantage of a discount
so powerful that it could be against the
law
head on over to joinpackman.com and grab
a membership and in all seriousness
uh it's two bucks a month if you use the
coupon code and if you pay for the
entire year
it's a dollar eighty we're not talking
about a lot of money now
if you think what i'm doing is bad don't
sign up
if you think i'm a bad person don't sign
up if you can't afford it don't sign up
okay because the show is still going to
be here for everybody but
if some combination of the following are
true you like me
you think the work we do is valuable and
you can afford a dollar eighty a month
then come on over go to joinpackman.com
uh
and sign up and some people who did that
are kathleen taylor who's new member
number nine
natalie solomon is number 10.
uh josue josue gonzalez is number 11.
uh i know i'm missing some hold on
brenda kearns is number 12.
sally vecino over is number 13
and kathy markman is number 14. thank
you thank you and we're going to keep it
going
and if we get to 25 we'll go to 50 if we
get to 50 we'll go to 75 it's going to
be absolutely
crazy crazy what goes on today
okay um i still do have soup by the way
just so people don't go attacking legal
eagle this is fake okay this is not real
legal eagle did not really do a story
about how my membership discounts are so
huge that they are illegal that's not
true
this however is very real okay
i never leave home without my medical
plasma
anybody who knows me in real life knows
that
okay um
oh are people getting ba oh wow people
are getting banned everywhere that's
great that's too bad
yeah the banhammer is being dropped that
that's it actually is it is sad you know
i
i've never gone anywhere online and
trolled anything
ever so when i think about like what
must be going on in someone's life
when they troll live streams it's sad
it really is sad and um i just i more
sympathize with it like
house how bad are things for you
that you're trolling online streams you
know because you disagree with someone
politically or because you're an
anti-semite or for whatever reason it's
it's sad it's sad michelle marley
oh i just lost michelle's message
michelle marley says i'm terrified there
will be civil war
whether trump wins or loses those guys
all have guns yeah i have a number of
clips about that on my youtube channel
and it is certainly a concern
that the gun people may come out i am
very worried about that
for sure toxic trump tube says he really
is the trumpkin
orange on the outside empty inside has
to be thrown out in november
vote vote um
dan of earth says david how can trump
think convincing people that harrison
biden are to bernie's left is a good
strategy
i don't know i i guess my question is
whether anybody believes it
i don't know um
you know there's nothing marxist or
communist or socialist about joe biden
or kamala harris
it is it is a weird approach but listen
trump won the first time right
maybe he knows something we don't willy
okay i'm going to pronounce this willy
pisonia
says pad kid poured curd
pulled cod the tongue twisters are tough
shane skinner says we love our big
beautiful cheerleader in chief don't we
folks
danny's lay says i am in oregon right
now and it's burning thanks for carrying
trump
rodolfo avalos says should democrats
drop the defund the police i don't think
it does any good to the movement
uh democrats by and large don't want to
defund the police and
um i i i've spoke i've spoken about this
i'm not a defund guy i'm a reform guy
but by and large they're they're you
know
power democrats in power don't do not in
any serious way want to defund police
thank you to sacred light for
subscribing on twitch
um with the message you are under arrest
for these fantastic deals also remember
kids it's
september on twitch please also sub the
david pakman twitch
or as i like to call it deepak 2.
dragonfly back home has subscribed for
13
months on twitch can you believe that 13
months
[ __ ] has subscribed on twitch with the
message
i had to give plasma for this sub
um thank you metal gamer says
time for the orange julius caesar show
well said well said chris
stultz says i wonder if this is trump's
new covid response tactic
fly by super spreader events for herd
immunity
yeah trump is trying to get us to hurt
immunity by holding events
that's actually it that's interesting
that is quite interesting
um okay
we are uh yeah trump is certainly
starting late
certainly we're already 15 minutes late
there he is clapping
let's let's make sure we are in uh we
are in 720p
let's see if we have it whoa this one is
way behind there we go
now we've got it going we want this one
in hd as well
i want to bring you guys the best
quality video possible
it sort of looks like this may be the
best video right now let's see what's
going on sound wise
[Music]
okay it's i can't handle it guys i see
um okay so listen i don't want to take
up time
right now with the membership stuff i
see people signing up
we will very very much keep the number
up to date once trump starts speaking
i'll get caught up on it
but i want to read a few other super
chats trevor says his white house staff
tired of lying on trump's behalf
probably and do you think those working
for him are seeing that most people that
assume the role of defending him often
end up testifying before
congress that would be yeah i don't know
how clear they are on that phenomenon
but uh certainly a possibility before we
start here
let me remind you we are 3 000
subscribers from a million on youtube 3
000 subscribers from a million on
youtube
there's 11 000 people watching right now
let's get to a million right now guys
let's put this fight out of its misery
let's just do it okay we've got the
numbers
we've got the numbers we are at 996
we're just shy of 997 000 on youtube
we've got 11 000 people watching just
hit the subscribe button let's do it
and i will keep track of it during
during this event as you can see this
only updates every thousand we are only
about 50 from 9.97
um so so essentially it is down to the
last 3 000.
incredible absolutely incredible um
and if it does happen while trump speaks
how poetic would that be huh
how poetic would that be thanks to
puppy.exe
for gifting five subscriptions thanks to
artistic
simplicity for the sub on twitch becky
gurley has subscribed
fat gab has subscribed combo carl has
subscribed so has
emeronic and we are very very close to
another corona rally
wow i can't get any more volume on this
let's try a different one just uh just
just in case
maybe the volume is better here
it's just it's a low native volume
i've got volume master all the way up
let's see what we can get
[Applause]
we brought you a lot of car plants
michigan we brought you a lot of car
plants you know that right
long time it's been a long time since
you had all these plants being built but
we brought you a lot over the last three
and a half years and
it took one second to lie
hello michigan and i'm thrilled to be in
freeland
with thousands of loyal thousands
hard-working american patriots
virus 54 days from now we're going to
win michigan
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house
let's hope not
[Applause]
this is the most important election
in the history of our country a little
too loud now okay
joe biden devoted his career to
offshoring michigan's jobs
outsourcing
out that's i we shouldn't be smiling
about it
but we've changed it around outsourcing
that's okay trump laughs when it's
completely inappropriate all the time
your borders dragging us into endless
foreign wars and surrendering our
children's future
to china and other faraway lands
biden supported every disastrous
globalist sellout
for over a half a century including
nafta
china and tpp you know that
joe biden surrendered your jobs to china
and now he wants to surrender our
country to the
violent left-wing mob and you're seeing
that every night
[Applause]
wait isn't trump president how is the
mob because of biden
china wins if biden wins the mob wins if
biden wins the rioters anarchist
arsonists
and flag burners win
[Applause]
but i wouldn't worry about it because
he's not winning i don't think
we will see won't we
what a sycophant
you know this is not the crowd
of a person who comes in second place
you do know that
[Laughter]
the same thing happened four years ago
right
it was election eve but by the time i
got here it was late some of you were in
that audience at one o'clock in the
morning now election day
we had 32 000 people show up
and the reason i went is that i heard
that crooked hillary
clinton bill clinton and barack hussein
obama
hussein were traveling to michigan
because they heard they had
problems they were supposed to win
michigan but they did such a lousy
job that they had to come and get some
votes and they came and i heard about it
they said sir could you do it and i
hopped in the plane
we landed at 12 o'clock in the evening i
started speaking at one o'clock in the
morning now
election day 32
000 people she had 500 people i said
why are we gonna lose michigan and we
didn't
and we didn't you know that's true i
mean he won it by
what was it 11 000 votes and we've got
to make sure it doesn't happen again
he's right about this michigan could go
to trump again and that would be
horrifying
that's good or bad
i don't know i don't know if that's good
or bad because in all those polls where
we were down
last time we won so maybe we're better
off being down a little bit hello john
james i see you handsome guy
hey john james get out and vote for john
i'm going to introduce you in a second
john james oh god
what a job you've done you know i have
to tell you he took
i saw this group of people that were
running all nice people
three very rich people and one guy that
was john james
and i saw them all right i saw that
and i said wait you know with the
wonderful invention of tivo
one of the greats you can play it back i
said who was that
they said i don't know sir i said play
it back i said that man
is going to be a star it was john jay
and that was in the republican primary
and after learning about him with his
incredible career and helicopter
and he's a great and actually a great
flyer i heard the other day a great one
it's a really good one as opposed to
those that aren't so good
but his incredible uh background and
education
west point and all of the things he did
i said this guy
and i endorsed him and he went like a
rocket ship and
frankly if he had a little more support
he would have won the last time and this
time
i hear you're even and maybe even ahead
and we're gonna win for john james
imagine that and he's a great guy
but i'm going to introduce him in a
second i'm running for
re-election to keep jobs in michigan
and we have got a lot of you know last
year before the china plague came in we
have the china plague
thank you china very much
should have never let that happen okay
they should have never ever let it
happen they stopped it from going into
china
but they didn't stop it from coming out
here and coming into the u.s
in europe and the rest of the world 188
countries
but it is what it is and we're not happy
about it and we're going to remember it
we're going to remember it but we had in
michigan and in the country
the greatest economy in the history of
the world there has never been an
economy like that
you know even at its peak like things
weren't actually that great in michigan
michigan's had some struggles for some
time
by the way it's turning out to be john a
super v
no more v now it's turning out to be a
super v
but to put violent criminals behind bars
and to ensure the future
belongs to america not to china
because if we win america wins that's
what it's about if we win
america win
not only does joe biden want to
eliminate your jobs he wants to
eliminate your borders
he's promised to follow his state with
refugees and you know that as well as i
do and you see it all the time
from terrorist hot spots around the
world including syria
somalia and yemen biden's pledge to
have a 700 increase he made this deal
with crazy bernie
a 700 increase in the flow of refugees
so he wants to lift it up by 700
this is in their manifesto manifesto
he's also pledged to terminate all
national security travel bans
overwhelming your state with poorly
vetted migrants
from jihadist regions making matters
worse
he would open the floodgates in the
middle of a pandemic
and by the way the wall is over 311
miles long right now
wasn't it 295 yesterday
i hope he doesn't do mexico is gonna pay
for it let's see if he does that routine
uh oh trump having a problem what's
going on
[Applause]
biden is waging war against i guess
maybe he wanted his own monitors louder
yes i think most of you are not middle
class you're upper class
you're the elite you know the way they
talk about the elite the elite
they're really elite what they're not
elite you're the elite
elite has decided boy have we hurt the
elite haven't we
you're the super elite the left wants to
get rid of me
so they can come after you it's very
simple
over the last three and a half years
we've secured america's borders
blocked the entry of foreign terrors fix
our
disastrous trade deals and we have fixed
our trade deals good
was that a septic truck that just drove
by in the background
in fact maidan was interviewed today on
there they are cnn
[Applause]
it looked like it was either a septic
truck or the truck truck that um
uh sort of takes care of the porta
potties that drove by right behind trump
fine to be a nice guy i don't think he
likes me too much but that's okay
he was interviewed on cnn and they said
which is better
nafta or the usmca he said no no the
usmca
and tapper goes what couldn't believe it
said the usmca he made a mistake
from his perspective he made a mistake
because he doesn't know what's going on
even though he's right he doesn't know
they were a little
surprised to hear that they gave him a
few chances let's uh
ask that question again
but we brought back our manufacturing
jobs we rebuilt the awesome power of the
u.s military
we obliterated oh blitz
we obliterated the isis caliphate
and built the greatest economy in the
history of the world
and now we are doing it again bigger and
better than ever before
before the end of the year we will have
a safe and effective vaccine and we will
defeat the china virus i have a feeling
that
by the way i think the vaccine is going
to come very soon
[Applause]
the crowds like wait trump talked about
vaccines causing autism during the
primary
now he wants the vaccine do i clap do i
punch myself in the face do i question
my life for being at a corona rally in
other parts of the world
but the fake news doesn't like saying
that they don't like telling you that
and next year unless you have somebody
that's going to quadruple your taxes
raise your taxes
raise up all of those remember that
under biden taxes
for 82 percent of americans would not go
up
and also how do you quadruple someone's
taxes when they already pay 35 percent
what you tell them you owe us 10 that
it's insane
a choice between two parties in other
words give us all your money plus ten
percent it makes no sense
and two agendas for the future there's
never been a vision like this
you have sleepy joe and you have trump
quite a he's a choice
he's a beauty
he's a beauty
trump needs it louder again what's he
doing he seems not pleased with someone
over there
[Applause]
you know i watched the democrat debates
right and i watched them up there and
he was so bad i said there's no way he
makes it it's sad
isn't it the first lady actually came in
and one time she watched and she goes
and she's a nice person and she meant
this really me i view it differently
but she looked and she watched the
debate and she watched joe
and she said darling it's so sad
this was early on and this is the guy
i'm running against
[Applause]
okay it's so sad darling it's so sad
i don't think this story can't be real
because melania doesn't call trump
darling
he's put forward the most extreme
platform and it's not him
he doesn't know what platform he doesn't
it's your radical left people it's aoc
plus three it's uh all these people
bernie
it's bernie it's kamala the most liberal
person in the u.s senate
still with the kamala mispronunciation
my fellow battlestar galactica fans will
remember that kamala was the drug that
people took in battlestar galactica
our future vp might be kamala it was a
big plunge right down to the bottom and
then she dropped out
she dropped out but there's never been
anything like this and no major party
has ever had a candidate
that's so extreme in his views and again
he took the manifesto drawn up by bernie
in the super libs
and that's what he's going by including
a massive increase in your taxes
and a total assault on your second
amendment
wrong
on november 3rd michigan you better vote
for me i got you so many damn car plans
oh my god he's unhinged
he's losing it
this is an ill man
i'll tell you what i'll be so angry at
you
huh telling voters you'll be mad at them
isn't ideal right
is that right i mean have you seen that
what we're doing here all the plants
that have been built are being built and
what about the plants that are being
expanded they don't want to give you
credit for that they're just expanding
[Applause]
i went to prime minister abby of japan i
say prime minister you have to start
doing something you know he's a great
guy he'll be retiring soon he's a great
guy
yeah the prime minister of japan abi
i say shinzo shinzo you have to do me a
favor
you've got to send car plants over here
you know you're sending all those cars
we stupidly don't charge you tariffs on
those cars that pour into our country
i said shinzo you got to give us plans
no no no i can't do that
uh that is up to the free enterprise
system of japan i say shinzo
you're a powerful man you can do it oh i
can't do it the next day they announced
five
car companies are coming to michigan
right
i don't even think trump knows whether
this story is true
and you hadn't had a plant built now
they've been building it for a number of
years
but you hadn't had a plant built in like
42 years
you know they were the old plants and
it's been amazing what's happened in
michigan but honestly it's been amazing
what's happened in ohio
and north carolina and south carolina
and florida and
new hampshire and so many other places
our country
is doing great we had to take a pause to
get rid of the china virus
right and we got rid of we're getting
we're coming around we're coming around
that turn
i'm telling you you watch next year
better than last year it's going to be
better
certainly should be better than this
year anyway whether we will quickly
return to
record prosperity or whether we'll allow
sleepy joe to impose four trillion
dollars in tax hikes
ban american energy confiscate your guns
by the way when is obama gonna start
confiscating the guns that everybody was
going to have taken away during those
eight years
has anybody had those guns confiscated
yet
you know it's all democrat governors and
i think they do it for political reasons
you know because there'll be less
activity you'd be doing even better if
you had a governor that
knew what the hell she was doing here
so there was an over under on whether it
would take him three and a half minutes
to mention her
it did take more than three and a half
so
you have to have a governor because you
know right now michigan's lagging
great football great coach great team
it's lagging we want a governor john
james
that's going to let michigan play big
ten football this year
you've been seeing a lot of the other
schools want to open big ten
at my suggestion how about sleepy joe he
said
donald trump is against football no no
no where does
football rank on in terms of issues this
election
these people practice disinformation
like nobody has ever practiced that
they're liars i'll tell you they lie but
we have a good chance you have a very
good commissioner and the commission is
working hard and hopefully very soon
they'll say you're going to play
football
and i hope they're not leaving michigan
out because it's never the same if they
do but you're in maryland where they
have a problem
at in terms of playing and the governors
have a lot of power over that they have
a lot of power a lot of say
so let's play big ten football right
yep there you go elect this man
they want to shut down auto production
delay the vaccine
they want to destroy your suburbs look
at what one who who wants to shut the
shutdown auto
what is he even talking about and the
suburbs does anybody want to have
somebody from antifa as a member
and as a resident of your suburb it
means do you want black people in the
suburbs that's code folks that's that's
a dog whistle
say darling who moved in next door oh
it's a resident
of antifa no thank you let's get out of
here
let's get the hell out of here darling
let's leave our suburbs
uh i wish trump were president he
wouldn't have allowed that to happen and
that's exactly right i won't allow it to
happen
the suburbs are the american dream
and i will tell you i have protected
your suburbs you know i get rid of a
regulation
yeah that played with your zoning and
played with other things whether it's
projects into the suburbs of our great
country
so all that the regulation did is say
that
there should be research done as to
whether housing and zoning policy is
create
creating having a racial impact having a
racialized impact
that is discriminatory you have to
investigate that
that's what that that's the big thing
trump got rid of to save the suburbs
well i think the uh people living in the
suburbs which i know very well i watched
westchester
in new york where they were doing things
that should never have been done
it's not going to happen to our suburbs
they want to erase your borders
and indoctrinate your children with
poisonous
anti-american lies in our schools
right cue patriotic education
not gonna happen for the last four years
they've tried everything to stop us and
they are only getting more desperate by
the day
can you imagine if on september 3rd
they say ladies and gentlemen donald
trump
has been declared the winner did
[Applause]
at first they'll go crazy and then
they'll say okay it's time now
to be reasonable they will have had it
they will have had it
you know we were coming together as a
nation if a week ago they declared him
president i would have been concerned
that's true they were coming together
it was success somebody said what's
going to bring you together
and it was we were coming together i was
starting to get calls from democrats
that
frankly we didn't speak much and i was
starting to get calls
and then all of a sudden we saw the
plague pour in and we saw what was
happening
and it really stopped things but success
was getting very very
close to bringing us all together and
then we had to say
let's take a timeout we got to fix this
mess beautiful super chat yeah
trump claims that the reason he kept
coronavirus
private in february was to avoid causing
panic
and then he's here saying black people
are going to move into your suburbs
that's my interpretation of it
and everything will fall apart you won't
have guns you won't have suburbs you
won't have anything if joe biden is
elected americans into their homes
while they encourage rioters and vandals
rampaging through all in all cases
democrat-run cities
you know republican-run cities are doing
very well i hope you know that
and i hope you know check out my segment
from two weeks ago
about how most cities are run by
democrats because democrats tend to
prefer urban areas
um and that this is it's
one of the dumbest arguments that donald
trump has focused on just did in
wisconsin which was so amazing three
days and we went in
and by the way the u.s marshals went in
to get the killer
right and that was the end of that they
got the killer they got the killer
you know what i'm talking about
and we were going to go into seattle the
next day
we're all set all lined up looking
forward to it we just said we're doing
it
i mean they actually took over a part of
the city and the mayor said
this is going to be a summer of love
right where do these people come from
but we're all set to go in they heard we
were going in we informed them we're
going in and they sent their police to
do it
and we never even had to go in but we
can solve those problems
in a matter of literally minutes
thank you
okay
all right
[Applause]
what is that don't say that i'll start
to cry and that wouldn't be good for my
image
we don't want to you don't want to see
me cry
i'll start to cry you know one of the
fake news broadcasters uh
because this happened the other day we
had a tremendous crowd like this weird
i mean we had a tremendous crowd in
north carolina they started chanting we
love you we love you we love you
and you know it's incredible they said
with all the years that they've been
covering presidential elections they've
never heard that chance
right well it's a cult-like chant we
love you
to win to it this is the deification
of elected officials i don't want to see
it with anybody that this is not how we
should even be thinking about elected
officials
it's cult-like you know now they'll say
now they'll say they'll say he
misrepresented 18 years ago
there was a rally held by somebody
and we heard the words from two people
that we love you sir
okay this is what we're dealing with and
by the way i look at
there's a lot of people that look at
this
there's people back there that can't
even get in yeah thank you pandemic
going on pandemic
thank you it's really nice to be with
you as president
i will always support the heroes of law
enforcement
i've mentioned this before but the
transitions from his musings to the
prompter are so
of the jarring officers association of
michigan where are they
where are they
they're here someplace
thank you fellas that's really nice i'll
tell you that's an honor
i have to be honest i got it from
florida texas ohio
north carolina south carolina but
michigan is michigan
thank you okay
i don't think there's any law
enforcement officer that
is against us what is our poll number 99
i know they had 365
000 at one group and they got a
unanimous vote i said that's pretty good
unanimous how can you go the other way
you people
are fantastic and we love you thank you
that's great thank you very much
appreciate it what poll was that
biden says he wants to protect black
lives but his radical platform
will cut short the lives of thousands of
young african-american
citizens thousands the murder rate in
democrat-run cities like chicago
baltimore new york so many others
is higher than in afghanistan yet biden
supports
imposing these failed policies
nationwide
you will have crime like you've never
seen before
you'll have crime like you've never seen
last week
there is no correlation between
democratic presidents presidencies and
crime portland district attorney who has
a policy of releasing rioters criminals
and violent extremists without charge
[Applause]
biden's plan and every time i say
biden's plan it's not his plan it's the
people that tell him what they're going
to do so
please understand i just don't want to
say that every time i mention his name
so it should say the people that control
biden's plan
is to appease domestic terrorists my
plan is to arrest them to lock them up
okay
you really have to be dumb to fall for
this stuff like but biden will stop the
prosecution of terrorists what
what are you talking about the
department of justice
the department of homeland security and
the united states
supreme court and we can't let that
happen
right no city town or suburb will be
safe
on november 3rd your vote will save
america
remember it's the most important
election we've ever had
so i'm joined tonight uh-oh by some
great warriors that have
really helped me a lot in washington
with the fake impeachment the
impeachment hoax
here we go russia russia russia hoax
somebody said russia's coming up again
adam schiff said we'd like to find out
about
i said what about china what about other
countries there's always russia
that's a russia they're at it again
well i want to just thank these guys
because these were real warriors for all
of us
they love your state and they love our
country congressman
jack bergman
okay great job jack
[Applause]
john mullinar oh that's that's some
risky reading there
right great going john he's a tough
cookie
and tim wahlberg tim thank you is that
one of the wahlberg brothers
what great people and i talked about him
a little while before i could talk about
him all night he's a star he's going to
be a future star
you know we have a very much different
party than we had four years ago
we're now the party of the workers we're
the party of a lot of
different things now yeah but we weren't
really considered the party of the
workers
certainly not anymore remember this
we're the party of abraham lincoln a lot
of people forget that yeah of course
that well people forget it because it's
untrue because there was a complete
reversal in terms of the parties
remember that that may be i mean again
you really have to know
nothing to fall for these stupid bullet
points should it be presidential i'd
only have about
10 or 15 people here you'd be bored
but remember i used to do that but i'd
always say
i can be more presidential than any
president in our history
except for the possibility of abraham
lincoln when he wears his hat
we've not seen that that's tough to beat
john we've not seen that
but seriously if you want to be well
represented you know
your current senator i don't even know
this guy
i don't even know this guy nobody does
they don't know who he is they don't
even know
he comes into the office i say who is
that guy i know every senator
democrat republican i don't know this
guy
i know your other senator i can tell by
her hair she's got
interests
this is the president by the way john's
first crack he learned a lot
and frankly and i mean this if he had
more support from the republican party
he would have won that race
he would have
but this guy peters right peters i say
who's peters
nobody knows him he doesn't do anything
i really mean look we're going to end
this but i have to tell you john james
i hope he means he's going to end this
rally his whole he loves our country
he's been he's been educated at the
highest level
he was always the top at everything he's
ever done
and this is what he has and i'll be
honest with you
uh john i think i can tell this story
john and i were thinking about john
i was thinking about john more than
myself because i know talent
right and i said you know john you can
run for a certain
house seat right and you're guaranteed
to win
you can run for another house seat it'll
be a tough race but you're going to win
or you can have a tough race against
somebody that
nobody ever heard of it's like a habit
that they press
that particular trigger but that's a
tough race
what on earth is this guy talking about
or
you can take a shot at this one he said
sir i can do more in the senate that i
can do in the house
and that was his decision
right took a lot of guts
so john uh i'm with you you have my
total and complete endorsement you have
everything i can do
everything i can do we will do for you
and i really believe you're gonna make
it you're you're running against
somebody that is just
ridiculous folk it's ridiculous don't do
it
also with us are some other great
candidates and people that are going to
do a tremendous job helping our
congressman
paul young where's bob just while we do
this i'm going to put up my old
trump bingo card and just see if i'd
have bingo based on this okay i'm going
to put it up right now
i'll put it in the chat as well lisa
great job it's going well
and eric isaki
thank you eric good luck good luck we're
going to be out here helping you too
we're going to be out here
i hope john doesn't even need help but
we're going to help john too
we're going to help all of you all right
we're going to be doing oh god sorry
guys
rnc chairwoman you know she was the head
of the whole state
and she kept calling me back back sir
one more speech you're going to win
michigan hadn't been won in decades
one more speech sir you're going to win
michigan i'd say all right
ron i'm coming in one more time but
that's it i said that woman is the most
aggressive person i've ever met
she said i'm telling you sir one more
speech
i said i'll do it one more time but
that's it
about a day after i got back i said i
just got back from michigan it was
wonderful i get a call from ronna
mcdaniel
and she goes sir could you come in
tomorrow for another speech
well whatever happened she is the one
that got me here at midnight
on she is
so when it came time to picking the head
of the rnc you know as president you
have a couple of things to say about it
right
i said who's that woman that kept
getting me back to michigan
boy oh boy she'll be great ronna
mcdaniel
that's about where i'm at
and somebody's doing a fantastic job and
tells us we're
really pretty far ahead maybe way ahead
you know
they had a poll i think it was a gallup
poll they said 62
of the people are lying about their poll
now they're only lying i don't know if
i'm supposed to be
insulted by that or not but we'll take
it but we could have a very big win
and look uh no president has done for
michigan
what president trump has done for
michigan
and you're going to remember that and
i'm going to remember
michigan michigan gop chair
laura cox
great thank you great job great job
thank you
thank you very much thanks laura i hope
we skip a lot of the
rest of the middle game and go right to
the end game if you guys know what i
mean over the last
47 years 47 years of bad votes
after the last administration nearly
killed the u.s auto industry
i saved the u.s auto industry
joe biden supported the disastrous
trans-pacific partnership which would
have been a death sentence
for american auto jobs i withdrew from
the tpp my first
week in office that was so easy that was
so easy
you wouldn't have been making cars you
would have been buying cars from foreign
lands we have enough of that
biden supported the horrendous south
korea deal
that would have wiped out u.s production
of the pickup truck
which is the most a pickup truck is the
most
profitable thing the auto industry makes
you know why
we have something called the chicken tax
does anyone know what i'm talking about
the chicken tack
it's a tariff of 25 and it keeps other
countries out of here
and it expired and south korea didn't
want to do it but they did it we got it
right back and we put it on for a long
time
and now you're making but remember this
go check it out the chicken tacks i'll
tell you why someday in another meeting
why they call it that
maybe you don't want to know about it
this guy's going to be so
triggered if he loses it's going it's
going to be historic good
and we're expanding our autos now our
cars and we're doing a great job of it i
want to thank everybody
doing a great job
and by the way many other things in
michigan
biden supported the outrageous fuel
economy standards that have hammered the
auto industry
and i reversed that rule i actually
trump's made it easier to pollute
we're going the wrong direction my
friends be able to afford
a car the united states lost 500 auto
and auto parts factories
under the obama biden disaster
before the virus my administration added
over 200 new auto and auto parts plants
in 2007 how about 200 i didn't know that
200 200 i thought it was a little less
than that when
i want to see that again 200 it says 200
do you believe it
this is trump's teleprompter comedy
routine
you know i have a choice between
teleprompter and
freelance and i hate to say the
freelance is always a hell of a lot
better but
if you remember and you remember well i
actually got elected because of
freelance we didn't have teleprompters
true in fact he said obama was bad
because he used the prompter
that 200 we're talking about 200 plants
i thought it was a much lower number and
i thought you should put me in office
based on a much lower number at 200 you
have no choice
[Applause]
yesterday yesterday
biden was in michigan he said i better
get out of the basement this guy's
starting to do very well
lying about his lifetime of cold-hearted
globalist betrayals
biden champion nafta perhaps the worst
trade deal in the history of our country
globalist betrayal to embrace and
promote
nafta for decades and i told you he just
said
it was not as good as the deal i made i
can't believe oh they're giving him hell
tonight
they're giving him hell what did you say
that for
boy oh boy yeah haydn joe hyden
yeah i see people in the chat saying
imagine seeing this and thinking i'm
gonna vote for this guy that actually is
the problem there's crazy people there's
there's
you know uh people whose businesses go
bankrupt
there's unstable people there's all of
it most countries are smart enough not
to elect them president
and the fact that this is going to get
more than 60 million votes in november
that's way scarier than the fact that
trump's an idiot
can you imagine if i lost to him i'd
have to say i lost to the worst
candidate ever put up
don't do that to me michigan
don't do that
biden supported china's entry into the
world trade organization which by the
way was a disaster
china was flatlining for years and years
and decades
and it got into this world trade
organization
with all sorts of advantages just a
terrible terrible situation took place
and that's when china
became a big powerful economic power but
if you look at the numbers just before
the plague now the numbers are different
we were going up up up we were beating
them like a drum
they weren't even close we were gaining
gaining gaining
we were number one by far you know for
years i've heard that in 2019
china was going to surpass us well in
2019
we gained a lot on them we were doing
great right
we were doing great and we'll be doing
even better next year you watch
yesterday it was revealed that a fun
partly owned by joe biden's son where's
hunter
oh he talked about this earlier i think
that this story is not going to land
with anybody
now name his first name is where
where's hunter
he must be a brilliant guy because with
no experience he's taking
more money from more countries kind of
like his kids no job and then it became
rich
but where's hunter facilitated the sale
of a michigan
automotive company to a leading chinese
military defense contractor does anyone
know that china's military got yet
another piece of
american manufacturing might and the
biden family made a lot of money on it
a lot of money
what about ukraine he got a hundred and
eighty three thousand dollars a month
three million dollars up front and he
had no experience with
energy working for an energy company by
the way
sort of like trump's kids have no
experience working in government and yet
ivanka and jared are highly placed
advisors at the white house weird 183
000 a month and we'll give you an
upfront payment hunter of three million
dollars
will that be satisfactory he goes yes
i'll take it
would anybody here not take that deal
anybody please raise your hand
it is one guy right you must be a pretty
rich guy
if biden's elected china will own
america
washington vultures like biden and
others
ripped apart entire towns all across
your state
michigan lost half of all manufacturing
jobs
after the trade deals that biden
supported
and by the way i don't know if anybody
does anybody remember like 12 years
ago long before i thought about running
for president when i enjoyed my life i
had the greatest life
where would we like to go let's go to
monte carlo this weekend let's go
[Music]
really relatable guys let me fly my
private plane to monte carlo
very well i was honored in michigan does
anybody know that
i would the man of the people award by
somebody
and i came in
and i spent like 45 minutes talking
about
how you've been ripped off how all your
auto companies are leaving and going to
mexico and by the way to canada too
but how they're all leaving going to
mexico and canada i spent the whole time
talking about it i said
at the end i felt embarrassed i said i
hope i haven't insulted to sing too much
but why do you let this happen i stopped
it
i stopped it
won't be happening it won't be happening
it's not going to happen anymore biden
took a sledgehammer to your state
earlier this year i kept my promise
to michigan workers when we ended the
nafta nightmare that everybody said was
impossible to
end and when we signed that brand new
u.s
mexico canada agreement into law the
usmca includes powerful wage
protections to keep auto manufacturing
jobs right here in michigan now they
have a tremendous disincentive to leave
michigan
fire all of our workers go to mexico
or canada make the car or the product
send it in here without tariffs we end
up with closed factories
no job and no taxes that's not happening
anymore that's not happening anymore
but you remember how bad it was just
before i took office it was
it was like an avalanche of companies
leaving our country
no i also took the toughest ever action
to stand up to china's rampant theft of
michigan jobs
biden has vowed to remove these tariffs
and allow china to resume its pillaging
just so you know china's paying us tens
of billions of dollars a month
remember american companies pay the
tariffs
when they buy stuff from china has
nobody explained it to him
or is he just lying i gave it to our
farmers i don't know if we have a lot do
we have farmers
we have farmers raise your hand farmers
yep the whole crowd is farming
the whole crowds farmers which was why
the story about flying to monte carlo on
a whim was such a great story targeted
they said you know and that's what they
did to the past to other presidents
they said if you do this we're going to
stop doing business with your farmers
and you're not going to be able to get
any votes and you're going to lose the
midwest and all of that
and i said you know what i'd do whatever
you want then i went to sonny perdue
secretary of agriculture a great guy i
said sonny
how much are they being targeted for sir
12 billion dollars the first year two
years three years ago
and then 16 billion a total of 28
billion
i said that's okay we're putting tariffs
on everything they
send into our country what an economic
mind this guy is huh
also 10 and 12 all different tariffs
we took in billions and billions and i
said you know what we're going to do
we're going to take of that the 12 and
the 16 28 billion dollars
and we're going to give it to our
farmers who were targeted
and our farmers are doing great so
you're giving the money
the tariffs paid by some american
businesses to other american businesses
meanwhile china just keeps selling their
stuff got it okay genius
hillary wouldn't have had a clue crazy
bernie wouldn't that nobody would have
had a clue on that one
sounds like social media by the way we
had billions tens of billions of dollars
left over you know what i did with that
we gave it to the u.s treasury
right smack into the heart of the u.s
trade smack them with it
and we're still getting those big
tariffs even though we made a trade deal
with china
i said no you got to leave the tariffs a
lot of people didn't know it schumer
went
well i don't like to do first of all he
didn't like tariffs then all of a sudden
he loved it
but when i made the deal with china i
left the tariffs on 25
and some different amounts but i left
tariffs largely on
and nobody could believe it they said to
schumer what do you think of the door i
don't like it because he got rid of the
tariffs i said no we left the tariffs on
this is what it is no matter how you do
it no matter how good the deal they'll
say it's no good
because they don't love the country they
don't love the country remember that
joe biden's agenda is made in china my
agenda
is made in the usa
agenda
he should rap guys this is really bad
that's a nice plane oh my god
somebody said to me your plane's just as
nice as that i said no it's not
that's air force one that's the nice
thing that's the number
always that's the nicest thing okay i
also authorized millions of dollars to
save michigan soon
i'd forget forget all the problems they
had
the smoothness with which he goes from
bragging about his 747
into lying about the things he did for
people in michigan with
no jobs is is really something else
mission initiative
and we have done a job on the zoolocks
they were rotting
you weren't going to have anything come
through the stool off
it's all done that deal is all done it's
all done right thank you
thank you where are my guys there good
job right even though you're law
enforcement that's a good job right
okay two months ago i also issued a
major disaster declaration
in response to the catastrophic flooding
caused by the failure of the
edenville dam
where are the people from eatonville i
like d-a-m-n in the subtitles on that
that was nice
no that was a terrible thing and they're
working very hard right now
we're providing more than 43 million
dollars in federal funds to help
homeowners businesses and communities
in central michigan to recover from that
catastrophe
please thank me and you know it's a
privately owned damn i think we're gonna
have to sue the ass off of the company
that has it i don't know
there you go i don't know why we're
doing it
i'll tell you why we're doing it our
great congressman thank you congressman
great job
thank you is he high right now i can't
tell
he called up he said uh sir we have to
do it it's a private dam i said well if
it's a private damn don't they have to
do it
say it will never happen right but we'll
end up getting some of that back i think
great great representative you have i
want to tell you he fought lucky
thank you perhaps in no area
have our opponents more thoroughly
portrayed working families of all
backgrounds than
on the subject of immigration
under my administration we've achieved
the most secure border in american
history
we've ended catch and release stopped
asylum fraud and we've deported over 20
000 vicious gang members and over a half
a million
criminal illegal aliens
as i said we've all i think it's so
funny how in the pre
it as the as we're waiting on the rally
the youtube audience is just going like
this
and then once the rally actually starts
it just trickles down
it's like that the idea of the rally
sounds okay
then people see it and they're like oh i
don't i don't need to be watching this
i'm out of here it's military
all made in the usa by the way all made
in new york
you know with the fake news today i said
and we have
systems and missiles and rockets and
military and tech we have systems that
you've never even seen before
president xi has nothing like it putin
has
nothing like it nobody has anything like
what we have
and they said is he giving away military
information no
i'm saying we have the greatest weapons
in the world that's what i'm saying
there you go
i'd love for him to comment as someone
pointed out in super chat why we're not
allowed in almost any country now don't
worry about it
these people are sick
never speak well about our technology
because you're giving away classified
information now
i just want to let people know we have
the greatest systems the greatest
equipment
and the greatest people right anywhere
in the world there's nobody like the us
military
most powerful we have the most powerful
military in the world
and when i took it over it was depleted
it was in trouble it was exhausted from
these ridiculous endless wars that last
nineteen and two remember three days ago
people were like trump just called out
the military industrial complex here he
is again bragging about all the weapons
he bought
they're all coming home and we launched
the first new branch of the u.s armed
forces in nearly 75 years since the air
force
we launched the space force very very
important
we passed the mission act we call it va
choice and va
accountability we hold people
accountable if they don't treat our vets
good you're fired get out you're fired
that's an obama policy veteran's choice
for in 47 months
than sleepy joe biden did in 47 years
that's true
we did more that sort of has a nice ring
to it right
think of it we did more and it's true
just
take it take a look space force by
itself that would be a major achievement
and with us we did so many things so
many things
but we did more in 47 months than he did
in 47 years it's true
it's true
[Applause]
and a lot of what i did is destroy some
of the horrible things that they did
including regulations all over the place
i withdrew
from the last administration's
disastrous
iran nuclear deal bad idea
we paid 150 iran did nothing wrong trump
bails now he thinks iran will do a new
deal with him why would they you can't
trust him
1.8 billion in cash in cash
you guys ought to take a look at that
please i kept my promise
recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
every president said they were going to
do that none of them did it for decades
and decades they all said
and i tell the story you know it was uh
a hard thing to get done it was easy to
talk about in the campaign we're going
to open up
the embassy in jerusalem we're going to
make it
it becomes automatically the capital of
israel that's everybody said it for very
very many decades for decades
many presidents but i realize that it
doesn't automatically become anything
that's a really dumb comment i was
lobbied by everybody please
don't do it don't do it don't make the
capital
of israel jerusalem don't move your
embassy okay so
what he's saying is the u.s will
recognize it but that's very different
let's do it anyway
it's true and the word got out
the word got out that i was gonna do it
and i was called by every king and every
queen and every prime minister and every
everybody was calling me please sir
don't do it please
so i did what we sometimes will do in
business
i told them when a king calls
when somebody calls and a mirror when
somebody calls
tell them i'll call him back in a few
days
i'm sorry sir he won't be able to speak
right now he'll call you back on
wednesday
okay thank you very much i appreciate it
on tuesday the panicked people who keep
walking by in the background
after that septic truck are just
cracking me up
and then i got on the phone with 18
different companies i go hey how you
doing you called i'm just returning you
call oh it's too late sir
we called about israel it's too late i
said yeah i'm sorry i wish you got to be
a little bit sooner
i recognized israeli sovereignty over
the golan heights
and we achieved the first breakthrough
in middle east peace
in decades
and by the way on wednesday i believe of
next week
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
and as you know the country very
powerful very respected
country with a great leader
uae is coming to
the white house and we're going to sign
an agreement that hasn't been signed in
many decades
well it's a new agreement has never been
signed it's a new agreement recognition
of israel and all of the things nobody
thought it could be done
and you know it's an amazing thing i
don't say this out of ego
but i was nominated right for the
nobel peace prize he was nominated by
some right-wing nut norwegian politician
it's really a joke and we know if obama
got one trump has to have one he just
has to have one
now i i have to tell you that's sort of
a big thing and
the networks and most of the news didn't
cover it can you imagine
when obama came to office they said
we're going to give him the nobel peace
prize there it is he actually said
what did i do i didn't do anything
that's what this is all about guys he's
even saying it
obama obama obama but he said what did i
do they gave it to him in a matter of
weeks
by the way i think giving it to obama
was questionable as well but that's not
what this is about this is about trump's
constant jealousy
unending envy remember north korea
remember they were going to be at war
with north korea where's the war
where's the war well what's funny about
that is trump can
confirm to bob woodward we almost did go
to war he almost did go to war with
north korea he admits that to bob
woodward
happens all i know is we're not in war
and that's okay they said but he gave
away so much i said i gave away nothing
no he gave away so much when i said what
did i give away you know what they said
uh we don't know i said here's what i
gave away i gave away nothing
they said oh but you agreed to meet oh i
see i agreed to meet so now they're
saying i agreed to me it was such a big
deal
instead of being in a war i think
agreeing to meet is okay right
and we did he's a different kind of a
guy and he's a
smart guy smart very smart guy we get
along
you know getting along with foreign
powers is not a bad thing we're trying
to teach that to the media and these
guys
that ran our government for so many
years these
fools right fools
you know you got nuclear weapons you got
big armies big davies
he gets along with putin that's a
terrible thing no it's a good thing if i
get along that's good he likes me
i like him not so bad he gets along with
kim jong-un
that's a terrible thing no it's a good
thing i'm trying to convince him
it's okay it's okay not to go to war
it's really okay no all right
he gets along with president xi he gets
along with prime minister abi he gets
along with a lot of people
and it's okay that's a good thing it's
it's really hard these stupid people
that have been running this operation
for
30 40 years and they come what's funny
is he didn't really get along that well
with the japanese prime minister and
their stories of the japanese prime
minister's wife going out of her way to
avoid having to talk to trump
and even if it were true that he got
along with the japanese prime minister
nobody would really be concerned about
that
these people don't know what the hell
they're doing and it's one of the
reasons i got elected i can tell you
that
poor woman is right we don't like his
foreign policy
i think twitch chat is right i think
that i think that shinzo abe's
wife pretended not to speak or
understand english to try to get out of
it yeah we're doing a great job for you
we're doing a great job for
michigan just to finish in the middle
east we killed the founder and leader of
isis al-baghdadi
he should finish the whole thing never
mind the middle east and by the way
we're pulling back and we're doing
everything so beautifully
if we do get into war we win the war we
don't fight for
nothing right we fought for nothing
we don't ever want to have war but if
there is a war
nobody's gonna even come close to being
able to beat us so we won't be depleted
from fighting in all these ridiculous
locations but he's against wars you guys
remember
stocking up on weapons threatening
people sending warning bombs
but he's against the wars 35 years
we took out the world's number one
terrorist
and the mass murder of american troops
kasim
salamani is dead still struggling with
that one
we kept america out of new wars and
we're bringing our troops back home and
they're coming home very rapidly you see
combing home that's weird
sleepy joe biden voted for the iraq war
not supportive the defense sequester
that gutted our military destroyed our
military set us back so many years
i got rid of it immediately he opposed
the mission to take out osama bin laden
he was against
it everything he did yeah trump so
against war there's no country he won't
bomb to prevent one
secretary of defense secretary of
everything he was sort of like he had
more jobs than any human being i've ever
seen
but he said everything everything that
biden
was for was wrong he opposed killing
solomani
he oversaw the rise of isis he was
unable to do anything with isis you know
i had
the leader of a very important country
in my office recently and he said and
i'll probably
refer the press they'll say who is it he
said thank you sir
you were the one that got rid of isis
the service i said
i was the one you're actually giving me
credit he said absolutely
when you took over isis in iraq
and isis in syria was all over it was
growing at a level like we've never seen
you came in
right and you absolutely wiped it out
happens to be
happens to be the man that said that
happens to be
the leader of iraq and he was very nice
he was very generous in his day because
he came to the white house two weeks ago
should fact check that we cheered
as we looked at all of the success that
we've had
successes he really oversaw the rise of
china as a positive development remember
he's gotta end this
development for america and for the
world he's been in washington for 47
years now he's all of a sudden
going to change it's going to change
it's not going to change
don't forget he was in washington in his
prime time which was never considered
gray
and now it's no longer prime time when i
banned
travel from china biden called it
hysterical and xenophobic
if we had listened to joe hundreds of
thousands more americans would have died
from the china plague biden was willing
to sacrifice american lives
on the altar of open borders and now joe
biden is once again hurting innocent
people
with his dangerous anti-vaccine
conspiracy theories obviously that's
insane
to allege the reason he's doing that is
he knows we're right next to having
a vaccine so he wants to belittle the
vaccine because he doesn't want us to
get credit
but again it's not him it's the people
surrounding him when the virus arrived
we launched the largest national
mobilization since world war
ii recently i visited the workers
at ford's historic ravensworld plant
who converted their factory to produce
tens of thousands of ventilators
after we invoked the defense production
act
and they've done a fantastic job
not a single american who has needed a
ventilator
has been denied a ventilator any time in
our whole
country they needed a ventilator we had
nothing we were left bear cupboards i
always say the cupboards were bare
it does sort of seem like he's starting
to come down therapies
and have achieved among the lowest case
fatality rates
anywhere of any country in the world
[Applause]
europe's excess mortality rate is 24
higher than the rate in the united
states
you don't hear that from the fake news
america will prevail over the china
virus
as franklin delano roosevelt said the
only thing we have to fear
is fear itself that's it
we're doing very well as the british
government advised the british people
in the face of world war ii keep calm
and carry on that's what i did
this whack job that wrote the book he
said well trump knew a little bit
they wanted me to come out and scream
people are dying with that
no that's exactly what he did on the
caravan
on biden on all of this other stuff why
wouldn't he do it
we have to leave
when hitler was bombing i don't know you
know this one hitler was bombing london
churchill great leader would often times
go to a roof
in london and speak and he always spoke
with calmness he said we have to show
calmness
right no like when trump said 15 cases
will soon be zero he was just being calm
guys
all of those great generals all of those
great
admirals our great vice president mike
pence
they did a fantastic job
our doctors and they don't get any
credit
because they want to discredit us as
much as possible
because they want it to carry over to
november 3rd but we've done a fantastic
job
i think we've probably done the best job
of any country certainly of any major
country
anywhere in the world on the pandemic
there are minors through our historic
relief programs
we've saved more than 1.6 million
michigan jobs
and over 120 128
000 michigan businesses michigan has
already gained
and regained more than half of the jobs
that it lost
and if your state was ever allowed to
safely reopened by your governor who
doesn't have a clue
she's like joe
crowd's getting bored you would have
regained far
more than that open up your state madam
governor open up your state
just like crazy nancy pelosi your
governor is a liberal hypocrite
who lives by a different set of rules
her husband was caught trying to put his
boat
in the water on memorial day weekend
here we go while she was ordering the
people of michigan to stay in their
homes
and forcing businesses into bankruptcy
left and right
the biden agenda would collapse our
economy
and destroy this great opportunity that
we're having right now
he would impose job-destroying
regulations that would demolish
the auto industry you know on
regulations it took
in many cases 18 19 20 years to get a
roadway or a highway approved
we have it down now to two years we're
trying to get it down to one year
and it may get disapproved for
environmental or safety reasons
but we're going to know about it very
fast no more 20-year approvals or
disapprovals
okay
[Applause]
he wants to force you to provide free
government health care to illegal aliens
he will destroy your social security you
will destroy your
protections for pre-existing conditions
totally wrong and lie security remember
they said last time
oh trump is going to destroy social
security well it's now four years
we haven't touched it well he tried
actually by cutting the payroll tax
that's one of the funding sources for
social security he's trying to do it
um and of course biden would not get rid
of coverage for pre-existing conditions
biden would start with obamacare as a
framework
for better or worse it covers
pre-existing conditions i will provide
school choice to every parent in america
a vote for republicans is a vote for
safe communities great jobs
and a limitless future for all americans
instead of letting washington change us
despite all that we have been through
we are changing washington
and in conclusion although i hate to i
really do i hate to
no please please i hate to conclude
because i love being with you i do
i do
are they counting please conclude please
conclude
so in conclusion over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
oh people were chanting please make food
i got it
we will make our medical supplies right
here in the united states and right here
in michigan
we will enact fair trade deals that
create american jobs and grow
american wages right
we will rapidly return to full
employment soaring incomes
and record prosperity and that's already
happening
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
surge federal prosecutors into high
crime communities
and we will ban sanctuary cities
we will appoint prosecutors judges and
justices
who believe in enforcing the law not
their own political agenda
this is trump's wrap-up voice i guess i
would call it
citizens of every race color religion
and creed we will defend the dignity of
work
and the sanctity of life
okay we will uphold
religious liberty free speech and the
right
to keep and bear arms
[Applause]
and you're lucky i'm here because your
second amendment would be gone
if i wasn't obviously even if biden
wanted to he couldn't get rid of the
second amendment there's no interest in
it of course
we'll strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep out people keep them
out
of these horrible horrible situations
where they
hurt our country they hurt the people of
our country
and we're also going to be staying out
of the endless ridiculous
foreign wars in countries that you've
never even heard of
certainly countries trump hasn't heard
of build the most powerful missile in
cyber defense
we've already got it pretty much
and we will maintain peace through
strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require
the biggest thing that nobody even knows
about and it's all signed
and it goes into effect on january 1st
and you better make sure i win can you
imagine
this is going to be the biggest thing
and nobody understands what it is
you'll figure it out price trump doesn't
even know what it is
january 1st and further reduce health
insurance premiums and the cost of
prescription drugs
at a level like you've never seen before
i've already signed it
favored nations the drug company trump
signed it the next step is to understand
it
just all you have to do is take a look
at all the ads they're running against
me
favorite nations where we pay whatever
the lowest is in the world we pay that
number
we will protect medicare and social
security
and we will always protect our patients
we will always protect our people
we will protect your pre-existing
conditions as i said
america will land the first woman on the
moon
and the united states will be the first
nation to land
an astronaut on mars
we will restore patriotic education you
know what i mean by that
[Applause]
and we will teach our children to love
our country honor our history
and always respect our great
american plan
do they go right into ymca when he's
done what do you guys think
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
[Applause]
and i don't know if you saw it but
during the democrat
national convention in caucus they took
twice i thought i was sort of maybe they
made a mistake
i wasn't asking if people want me to
play ymca that's what they play at the
rallies edge of allegiance
[Applause]
and then they said oh well well maybe it
was a mistake it wasn't a mistake
that's where they're coming from don't
be foolish that's where they're coming
from and there's nothing that sleepy joe
biden
can do about it for years you had a
president who apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for michigan
right
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
and your coworkers and get out and vote
so important
trump's been ranting 75 minutes so far
for people wondering
from grand rapids to saginaw uh-oh here
we go from kalamazoo to
mackinac here's his crescendo and from
flint to right here
in free land we stand on the shoulders
of generations of michigan patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved nation
this is the state where henry ford
invented
the assembly line it's the place where
general motors
chrysler and kellogg general motors
that's one of his generals he hates
right
mission well you know this one right
michigan gave us motown right
[Music]
right can you guys confirm i'm not sure
what is my motown
we love motown michigan gave us mo tank
gave us motown gave us the mustang
of the american midwest this is the
state where
tough strong and determined workers made
america into the greatest
and most powerful nation in the history
of the world
and we are making it greater and greater
every single day
right proud citizens like you helped
build this country
and together we will be taking back our
country
we'll be taking it back from people that
don't
love our kind hold on he's in power who
are we taking it back from
most complete we have to win on november
3rd
what it's like he's running against
somebody else who's president
we're returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning we are going to keep ordering
all right vote for john james john james
we need john james
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of michigan
we will make america wealthy again
cue the music we will make america
strong again all right
we will make america proud again
i hope we will make america
safe again what and we will make
america great again thank you michigan
we love you michigan thank you thank you
there it is
[Music]
what a guy
[Music]
impossible impossible to parody
indistinguishable from a skit uh donald
trump
in freeland michigan pumping his fist
let's see if he does his dance where it
looks like he is
um sort of hold there it is it's sort of
like he's um
uh like running a big piece of floss in
and out of his uh the two
sides of his mouth of his mouth or her
nose uh oh my god are you guys watching
this
can you believe what's happening right
now
[Music]
[Music]
what a victory ladies and gentlemen what
a victory
oh my god um thank you
to the 97 people 97 people who grabbed
memberships during
the stream let's make it a hundred at
joinedpakman.com let's just do it we're
at 97.
we're at 97 why not why not make it a
hundred and by the way
do we want to get to a million youtube
subscribers right now we're 2400 away
um we are right now at 997
600. okay we're at night we are 2400
youtube subscribers from a million do we
just want to do it right now because
otherwise
it's gonna happen during our vacation um
and i thought it would be an incredible
thing to just get it out of the way
um that's up to you guys
i don't know uh it's gonna be it's gonna
be a tough one
but um it's free by the way
people seem to think this costs money
it's free to subscribe on youtube it
costs nothing
i say we do it i say we get to the one
million right now as donald trump
uh can that fist pumping is something
else huh
let's see where trump wanders off to
[Music]
trump wandering back to the planet
[Music]
imagine having to stand behind trump the
entire
[Music]
a row of red hats here wow
wow
oh yeah people realizing we're also very
close to our
initial twitch goal of 50 000 followers
we are only a thousand
uh 1018 as donald trump carefully now
carefully walking up the stairs
presumably a turn and wave you often see
there it is we're in a little bit of a
clap trump being played out uh by
ymca um
yeah once we get to the million on
youtube then we're going to want to make
sure we get to 100 000 at least on
twitch put together something
respectable there for sure so there goes
donald trump another rally in the books
um yeah i should be thanking trump for a
million subscribers right there it is
uh okay ladies and gentlemen i so
appreciate everybody who did join me
joanne mckenna
and joshua davies just grabbed
memberships meaning we are at 99 out of
a hundred can you imagine
99 out of a hundred so close
so close um
we are on vacation next week but you may
see me pop in for a stream
maybe tomorrow before we leave uh maybe
next week if uh
donald trump resigns if really big news
breaks but uh we will we will see you on
the other side thanks for joining me
great to be with you guys on two live
streams today
and it looks like this stream is ending
buffering at least
and i am going to play myself out thanks
everybody
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives convalescent flows from strong
antibodies from the blood of recovered
patients to help
treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
[Music]
million lives to fund the